okay now that it's 10 o'clock Apple time
we can get underway and whoever would
like to come
join us
I would make a public announcement that
tomorrow we're canceling our work
session I would imagine most of you were
not going to make it anyway
well in that case we'll reinstated
okay welcome commissioner good morning
for the record Frank gadle blue
Commissioner of Education
Tammy Vaillancourt CFO
Caitlin Davis director
and so I just wanted to see if anybody
had any questions about the reading
material I handed out last time okay
yeah
um so good morning I mean I'm here to
kind of answer questions that you may
have relative to the budget and I can
walk through specific programs I have
this sheet right here
which we were provided by Mickey or I
have my hb2 language as well like what
is the easiest way for me to facilitate
walking through this with when we walk
through using this that document okay
yeah
great so then we'll start
um it is
going down so it says page 28.
in the left-hand column the first 28
there section 62 Department of Education
computer science and stem administrator
then the next line 28 63 Department of
Education computer science educator
program and then Pages 29 and 30 section
64 and 65 Department of Education
computer science Appropriations and so
those I'm going to talk about those
three because they have some
interconnectivity in terms of coming
together
um and really the first item on there
the computer science stem administrator
is my understanding and administrative
position in hb2 that was added in the
governor's budget to help us administer
the two subsequent programs so we can
talk to that
um the only uh difficulty with that is
is we don't see an appropriation for
that so while there's a
um you know computer science stem
administrator position that was included
to administer the programs that are
being implemented there was not funding
associated with that so if we decide to
go forward with those that programming
it probably would need some
Administration to take place
but then the next item that I will point
out is computer science educator program
and this is a program to encourage
current Educators so this would be
individuals who currently hold a teacher
certificate in the state of New
Hampshire
to add a certificate or a an endorsement
to their certificate in the computer
science area and so the goal there is to
increase the number of computer science
Educators that we have in the state to
make that more ubiquitous in our school
systems we do run a number of computer
science classes we've got a lot of
Robotics programming in the state and so
this is a program that would you know
allow those Educators to convert over
and essentially what we would probably
do is Target a thousand Educators and we
would provide stipends of 500 each for
those Educators to become to attain that
certification okay Mary actually I like
that idea um
this area
for many Educators is still a mystery
and we saw that when we had covered and
the re the difficulty with zoom many of
them had to do a lot
how do you see this happening
um will you will their training be
covered and step-ended I believe you
said correct um so what do you think
it'll look like because currently
quite frankly the current programs
usually in most schools are pretty dry
and they're not in context they're not
part of an application but I in truth
I've been away from schools for a while
so I may be all off but in my experience
they haven't been very exciting and the
exciting stuff is going on so tell me
about that I can't tell you about that
so first of all I'd like to just kind of
pull apart the um kind of what you were
describing there relative to what this
is so this is
um not for program so much as it is
getting the certifications for the
Educators
um the other thing I will mention is
with our Arps or funds and and so this
is specifically targeted at computer
science Educators we did provide two
million dollars of funding and worked
with Granite State College for all of
our Educators to be able to take a class
that would help them with the remote
instruction so it taught them you know
how to use canvas how to design an
online class and how to implement online
class so that I'm going to separate that
this is specifically associated with
allowing currently certified Educators
to add a computer certification so that
it's there are more opportunities for
students across the state vis-a-vis
those instructors and the way that that
would be administered is through a
stipend that we would offer to the
Educators who are interested in pursuing
that career opportunity so thank you
question I think Mr chair and thank you
commissioner for taking the questions so
I'm just trying to understand that this
500 would be the stipend for the educate
educator themselves this is not the
reimbursement for their training or
travel or testing expenses is it just
the you know compensation for taking on
the work and then those other expenses
will be handled by the district or by
whom no actually the inverse of that so
what this would be would be the 500 of
the cost for the Educators to attend the
courses or the programs to be able to
acquire the knowledge and the capability
containing the certification right this
is to allow them to become certified
thank you not for programming so
and then just I'm throwing I'm moving
forward just to keep moving forward but
we can come back to it but they all kind
of come together so that's what I wanted
to well I'm going to keep going forward
then you'll see there's an addition uh
the four million dollar appropriation
um it's actually a five million dollar
in total but uh is associated with
um expanding the availability of
computer science teachers in the system
by going outside of the traditional
certified Educators if you recall the
first program was about taking
individuals who already hold an educator
certification and allowing them to add
the certificate for the endorsement for
computer science educator this is really
to bring individuals off of the
sidelines we imagine that there may be
some retired individuals in the state
who have a lot of experience whether
it's in math or computer science and
allowing them to gain certification that
would take there's two ways that that
would happen and actually they you have
to kind of follow through both of those
but one would would be we would identify
a current computer
certifications industry recognized
credentials that individuals hold
whether it's like a Cisco license or a
programming license from a vendor right
so these are individuals who are
credentialed in the commercial world and
we would recognize those credentials
which would allow them to become a
certified teacher and then this funding
stream would allow them to add the
pedagogical capability to that
certification so that they would be able
to function as a certified teacher in
New Hampshire
Microsoft could be Microsoft would be
one that we would probably have I don't
know if we might not
you know credential someone who holds
like a an office certification like word
or something like that but more of the
serious certifications yes
thank you so this is essentially the
part where you are going and finding the
for the lack of the better word Geeks
and training them to be teachers that's
correct well I will be and that term is
an affectionate term term of effect I am
yes it is a self-inflicted term I was a
certified trainer for a while I only get
to say because I'm one of them but my
concern there and I just want to you
know state it for the record is that it
is actually it is
most of the time it is easier to take
somebody who's already a teacher and
teach them the computer skills they need
than it is to take a computer expert and
show them how to become a teacher those
skills are harder to acquire and you
have a much lower percentage of people
that can make the transition than the
other way around so just to share
because I've been in that field for over
10 years professionally and one of the
reasons why I was making the big bucks
was that I was one of the people who was
both very technically capable and could
teach but is the second part that's
harder to find so you may find more
success taking the existing teachers and
making them more proficient in computers
and the other way around but those are
very much worth exploring and when they
work they work spectacularly well things
and so you can kind of see how these two
programs are complementary in that sense
one is taking the existing Educators and
giving them the computer science skills
and the other is pulling people off of
the sideline and making them teachers so
question yeah I don't know if I
misunderstood um the people that you'd
be bringing in the computer science
professionals did you say that they were
certified already coming into the
program correct so what would happen but
not just that they were certified in
whatever they're doing it's just it
strikes me that the people I know who
are retired in computer science have
never have had a credential and these
are the superstars in the field who are
in the state
meaning that they are they meaning their
Silicon Valley Silicon Valley well Geeks
or whatever or high uh performers right
so I mean and so I'm trying to
understand the question a little bit
because it might be helpful for me as we
kind of craft the program but the is the
issue that those individuals don't hold
an industry credential yes okay
question yeah thank you Mr chairman oh
thank you for being here at Ronald
commissioner
um
how many different certifications do you
have now uh in specialties
you know like uh K is a K-8 uh High
School I mean yeah
probably more than 50. really yeah
interesting thank you question and I can
get the exact number for you but I don't
know what's on my head you know
so these would these individuals those
industry recognize sort of
certifications would allow them to
attain the computer science
certification not we wouldn't create a
new certification for you're an educator
of Cisco you're an educator of Oracle or
something like that
thank you thank you Mr Richard just to
quickly follow up on representative
Murray's comment it is a very valid
point there are people who get lots of
certifications and there are people who
have already established themselves and
don't need the certifications because
their work experience and achievements
prove it so I would urge the department
to be flexible when they try to attract
technical professionals and allow for
both Avenues
because proven capability and
performance is just as valuable if not
more valuable than a technical
certification so you know just like not
asking people to have a college degree
but just show they can do the job
if you guys can be flexible on deciding
who can do the job every one of those
methods work and I think you should open
all of them okay you know thank you I
mean in one way we might be able to
pursue that is really working with
perhaps Granite State College that has a
program where they recognize experience
and they're able to award certifications
based on that experience so we don't
have to build that infrastructure we
would leverage that infrastructure sure
other questions
are you ready to move on these items
let's let's start keep going oh you're
you're making an emotions yeah
go ahead
how do you plan to measure the outcome
of this program
so it would be the number of uh computer
of certified computer science Educators
that we have in our schools I was
thinking one level down the road how do
you measure that it makes an impact in
uh you know the outcomes for our
children I mean obviously in the short
term you'd you know be able to see the
number of people you are able to bring
in but down the road how do we
prove to you know the people we're
asking for the money from that this
money was well spent and improve the
outcomes for our kids and so we don't
have a computer science assessment so we
don't have a mechanism that would be
able to measure that and I think what
you'd find is that the computer science
particularly as you look forward in
terms of the instructional it's going to
be much more integrated in terms of in
other words like it's not going to be
siled like okay here's computer science
class and how many students are
participating it that really needs to be
integrated into
um you know the science curriculum and
all kinds of curriculum quite frankly so
I don't know that we have a mechanism
for measuring that it would be good if
you'd you know over time consider
developing some framework I know it's
not for today you are still a few steps
away from there but I would argue that
at the end of the day these types of
large Investments do
require us to look down the road and say
10 years from now yeah this worked
already this is how we can show
so so the initial metrics that we've
considered is the number of computer
science Educators yeah thank you
um thank you Mr chair thank you for
taking my question is this short term
okay this is a one-time thing and source
of funds
um
yeah General funds oh thank you
yes
I think this might be 23 laps actually
yeah
General funds Labs right uh before
moving on to the on these sections two
things that I'm just noticing the
commissioner talked about there's no
funding Associated to this new
administrator position that was
established so we haven't received any
estimates or requests relative to that I
don't do have a number
I know but we can get that for you
so so that that position is established
in House Bill 2 Section 62 but there's
no funding for it right so right now we
would have an amendment that would
establish the funding as a separate
section or put it in house bill one or
put it in as an appropriation here
there's two ways to do it but we just we
would need those numbers if you wanted
to fund that position as a committee uh
so just putting that
can we move on the item and then
okay I just wanted to make sure the
committee was aware that that would have
to happen and we'll get that information
but we're looking at something around
150 Grand
probably yes question could we just take
it out of the um
4.955 you can and that way we give you
authority to do that so it's coming out
it's already in there if you wanted to
repurpose some of the appropriation
because there's three different
Appropriations here
so you'd have to pick kind of where
you'd want that to come from
reduce one of those to add it to fund
the position do you have a press
preference Mr commissioner it should
probably come out of uh 64.65 I think is
the larger one
what do you want us to do just do 150
000 as part of the
or we can fund you know just allow us to
a fund a position a stem educator
administrator out of that section
correct do we have to say that that's
actually a good idea yeah okay yeah we
would and so so I can uh I can add that
from this appropriation
you know may also fund the stem
administrator in RSA 21n13 that's
established there the other thing I
think we just would want a little bit of
information on is on page 30 of house
bill 2. line eight where it talks about
the department retaining up to three
percent of these funds for uh
administering the program and that's
somewhat unusual to see a cost
allocation of General funds to support
general fund Administration so I don't
know if the department want to speak to
that because we we will see that later
in the education trust fund section as
well
uh page 30 line eight
it would give us enough so I was just
going to do the math I think that would
do it
yeah that's 150 so we'll do that but it
does say not it does say not more than
fifty thousand dollars so but more than
fifty thousand won't be adequate right
right that's what I'm saying yeah
yeah well finally
so where are we if I may yeah if we just
change the no more than 50 000 to no
more than 150 000 that would pretty much
cover an administrator position sure
strike the fifty thousand and leave it
at up to three percent I I would prefer
to keep the cap just because at the end
of the day this program May grow more
and I don't want to end up with a uh
expansive line item there but up to 150
should more than cover it and can be
adjusted further in other hb2s and
that's the end of my comment here talk
about a minute line eight correct in on
page 30 line seven eight just putting a
one in front of the 50 and then we do
not need to fund the admin anymore
that's the funds for the admin I suggest
that we're clear so the three percent is
about 150 is 150 000 of the
appropriation anyways yeah same amount
same way to get there
yep
um
make it 150. and it should be an up two
though
yeah because I don't wanna just like if
I don't need it I shouldn't spend it
right
okay
so so before we do that can I point out
that these funds say that they shall not
lapse the 150 000 would only be for one
year that would be the cost for one year
if this program went two years that
would be three hundred thousand dollars
for two years to support this program so
150 000 would only be one year of salary
so it should say 150 000 per year
the
yeah the cleaner way to do this would be
to appropriate money for the position
appropriate money for each of the three
components of this program right and and
this is where I'm getting back to the
retaining money from a general fund
appropriation to I'm not sure what that
if that is for the position that fifty
thousand was for the position then I
feel like you could take that out and
just fund the position directly
with that whole section take out that
Roman four on page 30 by eight and just
directly fund the position okay would
make would be a cleaner way to do it
all right
and then the only question would be if
you wanted to keep this Net Zero so
you're going to add let's say it's 150
000 a year for the position which
appropriation would you want to reduce
to do that so you've got the 4.9 yeah
so the 4.9 is 500 000 for one thing 4
million for another thing and 455 for a
third thing so if you go to page 29 of
House Bill 2 Section 64 you'll see that
breakout so we just want to make it
clear
if if the true intent here is to keep
this in Net Zero to fund the position
and still fund those
three Appropriations I think one would
have you'd have to have an offset I
would take it out of Roman numeral too
the four million dollar
that's the biggest basket of eggs
do you agree yes okay and I'll work with
the department to get the exact so we
fund that position at the proper labor
grade and step that they think it would
need to be because it might not be 150
exact but whatever
yeah okay
so we've moved are you blocking all
these items or just
want to do one at a time
uh
well I think I think Mickey has it been
doing we can do him as a group because
he he can he can do paperwork to it's
like uh so what he wants so then we're
talking about section 6263
64 and 65 with an amendment to follow
for
uh funding the position we would reduce
Roman two so the four million uh for the
purposes of encouraging individuals
holding it eligible so that Roman 2 on
page 29 would be reduced by the cost to
fund the position and then
would come out yeah correct
everybody in favor of that raise your
hand okay
I was just going to speak to it because
I had experience in high school
yeah I had experience in high school
where we didn't get electrical
electronics training
so when you take the test for the Air
Force you you pull you uh score pulling
so and then later on I
I did all right
okay
so that takes us to which section next
uh section 34 pay or page 34 section
is the teacher of the year program
and I do know that uh Deputy
Commissioner Christine Brennan wishes he
was here to talk to this because this is
one of her favorite programs
um and I will tell you that this year we
had more Educators apply and recommend
recommended as teacher of the year than
we've ever had in the past so very good
this would actually change the nature of
the program
such that this would become a funded
position so essentially the state would
be paying the teacher of the year for a
year to just be focused on teacher of
the year activity so the way that it
works now is the teacher of the year is
nominated they're in the school district
they still have teaching
responsibilities but we balance those
responsibilities with their
extracurricular things that they do for
Teacher of the Year this would allow
them to be full-time teacher of the year
as well as provide a stipend to the
school to be able to pay for someone
else to cover for that person
question thank you
thank you as we had the Kristen
McCullough award and I believe
over years that did a similar thing does
that still exist it does not it does not
I mean so generally the way that I fund
this now is I go out to Industry
partners and I ask for donations and
we've been successful getting close to
that as former deputy I too had to do
teacher of the year so I'm very familiar
um
anything that we can do to promote the
value of our Public School teachers I
think is of high value and actually it
would be great if we could do something
like this I really like the thought of
it
um and I would definitely support this
because I think
it's such a
a good
image to promote for our teachers across
the state
um and we certainly will have a lot more
interest in this program because now
we've got interest we have 300
applications I understand that which is
a great thing yes please so just to be
clear like when I first started in this
role like six years ago we had you know
10 or 15 people applying every year just
like nobody was doing anything but we've
just we've been out we've been talking
to Educators encouraging them to apply
encouraging people to recommend
individuals and we've gone from a
handful to hundreds these non-lapsing
funds
could we make them non-lapsing
it just then you have I don't even know
if that's necessary all right okay thank
you
right
uh thank you
um would would you still be going out to
your uh industry partners
I'm sorry I say that again oh would you
still be going out to your industry
Partners uh to get more funding uh to
you would only because I want to make
sure that they continue to have skin in
the game of the success of our education
system which is one of the advantages I
see to going out and working with our
partners thank you yeah so to make sure
I understand this correctly this is 250
over two years so it would be 125 a year
you said it will be used both to
basically compensate the teacher that we
pull out of the school to just be the
teacher of the year for a year and there
would be a stipend for the school
district I have only if we're not going
to pay people twice right so they don't
have to pay that teacher therefore right
so I was wondering why the stipend for
the school list yeah nobody's nobody
gets to double up I don't know what the
differential will be in terms of you
know if they have to bring into a
long-term sub and if there's an
additional incremental cost the the
intent of that is to just make sure that
the school district does not lose money
because that penalized exactly right
correct and then what would be the
duties of the teacher of the year as a
full-time teacher of the year I would
appreciate just a bit obviously I
understand the you know recognition part
but what would they do over the year
um so I don't think that that has been
fully fleshed out in terms of where they
would you know the the specific duties
that they would do but we imagine that
they would be doing
um a lot of training uh programming for
educators in terms of you know these are
the teacher of the years these are the
most highly recognized Educators um and
so how is it that they have been
successful in their classrooms engaging
students engaging their Community they
would be speaking to parents and parent
groups in terms of how to help their
children be successful in that
educational environment but the program
has not been fully developed thank you
question I just want to make sure this
is public school teachers public charter
and public schools this is for our
teacher of the year program which is a
public school thank you
other questions can I clarify that yeah
because Candace no we actually have
teachers the issuer from our non-public
schools as well because we've had Bishop
Brady in like a couple years ago yeah
they have to hold a New Hampshire
certificate
other questions
okay
I have a second to move the item
yeah all those in favor
okay
moving on okay page 57 line item
commissioner I'm sorry can we go back to
the Civics commission and the
appropriation yeah the two million for
the line enemas so we're on uh
Pages it starts on page 32 sections 86
through 88.
oh this sorry about that I didn't have
that one highlighted so I skipped over
that yes happy to do that
um so this uh basically creates the
commission on New Hampshire Civics which
includes a broad spectrum of
participants in terms of who
participates on that including three
public members appointed by the governor
uh the chair of New Hampshire civics or
their designee the Chief Justice of the
Supreme Court Secretary of State a the
chief administrative judge of the
Superior Court the chief administrative
judge for the Circuit Court Commissioner
of Education two New Hampshire Civics
Educators appointed by the commissioner
and two members of the House of
Representatives appointed by the Speaker
of the House one member of the Senate
appointed by the Senate President and
one member of the governor's office
appointed by the governor and
essentially the commission is tasked
with the goal of coming up with and
creating a textbook and related
curriculum and you'll notice that that's
something that the department has to in
the state is traditionally not involved
in curriculum development curriculum
specifically designed for New Hampshire
students and teachers to help them
explore history Heritage and and
principles of New Hampshire Constitution
and the government it established we are
required I'm not sure if they we don't
we don't have any um you know estimates
in terms of the funding but we're
required to provide a paper copy of the
published textbook available to each New
Hampshire classroom Civics classroom as
well as an interactive website some of
you may have seen the Civics program
that we have in fourth grade that was
developed by New Hampshire Civics which
is a great Civics program for our fourth
grade students about New Hampshire
government and New Hampshire history so
I imagine it would follow along the same
type of you know modality and
essentially that's what this
appropriation is for
Russian
is there a commission already or some
group of people working on this um I was
Betty camposi was asking me about this
and I assumed it was sort of the same
thing so can you tie those make the
connection for me there we can and they
are through the you know one of the
appointees to the organization from the
organization New Hampshire Civics which
is working on that effort so in other
words like so this is really now merging
those efforts so that their efforts
right now have been happening over here
that they merge with the rest of us in
terms of we're all working in the same
direction
question
thank you Mr chair I'm just concerned
about
um the ability of this to easily become
political
um what are the guarantees that it will
be a political in nature and it will be
unbiased
um just right now we are existing in a
highly political Arena and
civics
essentially should not be like that I
mean there are facts and
how to do things
and I wouldn't have a problem with it
but I fear
that
depending upon
the members of the commission
how it would be put together that's my
concern how how assure me that this
won't happen well I mean I don't know
that I can assure you I mean the
governor is going to appoint individuals
I don't know who he's going to appoint
um you do have a number of people who
are a political particularly you know
the chair of New Hampshire Civics the
Chief Justice of the Supreme Court you
know the Secretary of State the chief
administrative judge so there are a
number of appointees to this that are
apolitical positions and so I would hope
that it doesn't go there representative
Heath but I don't know that I even have
the ability to tell you that it can't
get there
when I worked at the department one of
the things that I had worked very hard
to try and promote was a Civics
curriculum that was Performance Based
and had activities like kindergarteners
would do some kind of a Hands-On project
first graders would do something and
second graders uh and then the fourth
grade that's kind of the full-blown um
you know talking with New Hampshire
history you know but it they would be
actively engaged in the learning and
they'd be some kind of a rubric that
would um look at it and so the kids
really had an understanding because they
really were part of it you know they'd
get their parents to go vote you know
they'd see how the process worked is do
you anticipate anything like that maybe
being in this book
so I don't know about that because as I
read this statute I don't know that it's
like it's a book and we have a K-12
system right so we're probably referring
to kind of a middle or High School type
of thing what I can say is and I think
you know
um you know I've demonstrated this move
kind of talked about it is the need for
engaging pedagogy not we're not trying
to put kids to sleep these days yes
exactly
all right so if I have any say over it I
can tell you that we will drive towards
you know uh engagement in terms of the
pedagogy and something this
performance-based maybe with activities
built in So when you say performance is
like a competency base like do we do you
learn the things or didn't you learn it
is that what you mean well with the
rubric that that
shows examples of different levels to
which kids achieve too yep so that would
be competency-based so so what is it
that you have demonstrated your ability
to do so all right thank you
yeah I have some concerns too I just
want to express
um you know we're living on a climate
where we are limiting what we are able
to teach in English you know the
legislatures are limiting to teachers
what they can teach in particular with
history and particularly with English
when something like the Diary of Anne
Frank was a required reading when I was
a kid and now it's banned in some states
you know this is bizarre and I worry
that this becomes a vehicle for going
down that path that has become a way to
put in restrictions of what teachers
should be free to teach
thank you I can assure you that speaking
for myself I don't plan to ban any books
whatsoever
um you know allowing parents to control
what kids may want to see that's a
totally different story but not Banning
books just to Echo though to follow up
on representative hits point
what I took her to say and what I would
say for myself is that I want to see
that kids as a result of whatever
resources we give them have the ability
to apply those not just repeat back
whatever the books say and I think
that's in a nutshell whatever language
you want to use about it what I I I'm
interested in seeing competence is that
you know can be tested and proven that
yeah that information can be used rather
than just repeat it back you know that's
where I'm coming from when I'm looking
at any outcome of an education program
so I want to hear you I mean I think
that that's both of you are just talking
about Good pedagogy right in terms of
making sure the students learn stuff so
Mary
thank you Mr chair I'm just wondering
about the funds if these are lapsing or
non-lapsing funds for this particular
item
was it uh
which is probably appropriate given the
amount of time that something like that
would take to make happen
well um just in another line of thought
so um
um I am a little bit concerned about
creating a print textbook in the age of
of modernization that we live in and I'm
wondering if the department has
considered an e-book instead so I share
that concern and in particular if you
imagine it says a paper copy of the
published textbook like that's was that
me one textbook per page so I see this
as really curricular materials that are
available to the actual classes where
that would take place
yeah it would be in canvas probably yes
thank you
um
did I hear that parents are going to be
part of this commission there are no
parents currently listed as members of
the commission uh to follow up
parents should have uh
some say in the curriculum I think
that'd be wonderful I mean we have no
objection to that maybe maybe they
should be added
I think that that would be a good
addition
hey big guy you're the one that's
what is it going to say
add a parent or a couple parents I mean
because we have like we have three
public members appointed by the governor
but you could also just say three parent
members but you could have you could
specify you know have three parents of
you know New Hampshire school students
say again
educated by a public educated or certain
or in a New Hampshire Public in New
Hampshire qualified education program
yeah
I mean
you know so that one of three at least
is a parent who will have a voice so
there'd be two at large and then one
defined as
parent of purchase of a student in a
qualified New Hampshire education
program okay I'm just saying again
because I see Mickey writing over there
what would we be comfortable with two
parents and one at Large
I'm just asking because again you know I
have no problem you know I don't want it
to be all patterns because there are
people who don't no longer have kids of
school agent yet have every right to be
represented I'm just trying to find a
balance you know
I I come to think of it I'm actually
fine with just one parent because there
is nothing to prevent the Governor from
adding more parents if they feel like it
but this gives them the more flexibility
and we made the point that we want at
least one parent so I'll I'll stick with
that and uh withdraw my suggestions
okay
so yes on page 32 of House Bill 2 line
37 where it's three public members
appointed by the governor we would add
something to the tune of one of which
shall be a parent of a student in a
qualified New Hampshire education
program okay good I would you know just
add I guess for argument's sake there
most likely one out of the three would
be apparent anyway I don't really know
if we need to get that specific about it
chances are one of those people will
have kids and I would just as soon I
would just as soon leave it open to the
governor to find three qualified people
as a people who just happened to have a
biological child or whatever so I'm fine
with the way that it is
um I don't like when we get too specific
about telling other people what to do so
yeah they're it's their choice I mean it
we we have in uh in our history
go go with civics
the U.S Supreme Court Time and Time and
Again has sided with the parents to
control the education and the upbringing
of their children and this is part of
them
Mary thank you Mr chair I'm opposed to
this
um I just think in our current climate
historically
we have not as legislators dictated
curriculum
um usually it's something we've left up
to local control we've set up standards
and guidelines at the department of Ed
but nothing this um
structured
um so I will be voting against this
thank you very much
other comments
so we're going to leave the parents in
or we're not going to leave the parents
as a vote yeah
we would move to include the one parent
language as suggested
um just because again while I completely
understand that you can have three
people who are not parents and be very
qualified to talk about Civics and
whatnot I think that having direct
access to you know the experiences of
one or more children in the current
schools would be helpful in just terms
of in terms of informing the commission
of what the you know situations are that
may arise on a daily basis and having
one voice to represent that out of God
knows how many members I'm not even
gonna go back out I think is a very
reasonable uh adjustment and we are
setting we are prescribing the
membership of this so clarifying that
prescription is fully within the bounds
of the committee in hb2 okay so all
those in favor of adding a language
about one school one parent of school
age
student whatever the words are raise
your hand on just that one
okay uh
4 to 40. all right
yeah five to two
I gotta get my hand out all right now on
the item uh before we go to the next
item if I just a clarification question
on an earlier item
we moved funds on the Department of
Education computer science
Appropriations we took funds to fund the
administrator position I want to make
sure I understand whether we moved 150
or 300 you know whether we moved the
150th per year or we did it for two
years and we are taking 300 of that just
to clarify that my understanding was
that it was 150 per year 150 per year so
we we moved a net of 300 out of the 4
million just making sure we're on the
same page I wasn't sure if that was
explicit to discussed thank you okay now
back to item 86 86 through
88 88
by Shoah
of this item all those in favor
all opposed
okay it'll go forward four to three
and just so the committee knows I'm
going to make a technical correction on
Section 87. you'll notice there's no
what we refer to as warrant language on
there the statement that says the
governor May draw a warrant against
funds not otherwise appropriate I think
that was probably just missed in
drafting so for that appropriation
section you'll see some different
language there just to make that
technical correction fine
okay
moving right along okay so item 163
is the definition of an eligible student
for Education Freedom account
and I don't know that there's a specific
appropriation associated with that
and I don't know and again I know you
have are taking this particular issue up
in a lot of different contexts so I want
to know
go over something that's already been
going over somewhere else but if there's
the appropriate Forum I'm happy to have
a conversation about it
and in particular what I'm referring to
is there is House Bill 464 which
ultimately will be before the uh the
Senate
so do we want to have that conversation
now or do you I'm sorry which item is it
um so it's okay it's uh item 163.
63 okay I was on the wrong page
57 yep
please okay
um so this is dealing with the
eligibility of the
um education Freedom account students
and
um one of the items that I saw in that
hb2 language that I know is being
considered by the various individuals is
um whose annual household income in
section uh 6A who's annual household
income at the time the student applies
for the program is less than or equal to
300 I know there's been conversation
about changing that number
um so and I would support a change to
that number if it was an increase in
that number
um but then otherwise the the really the
substance of what we had proposed was
one whereby we expanded categories of
eligibility for students to participate
in these efas particularly focusing on
students that are otherwise have some
type of a disadvantage in terms of
accessing their education some of those
individuals would probably qualify at
the 300 or 350 or 500 percent levels
anyways but by enumerating them in there
then they are not subject to that income
limitation test how you can see the
types of students that we're talking
about are Foster Care students migratory
students student who is homeless in the
state of New Hampshire
a student who is a mem you know whose
parents are members of the Armed Forces
who are you know quite frankly are
students who find themselves sometimes
um
you know moving around quite a bit and
their their education tends to get
disrupted so this may create some degree
of stability for them
uh our English language learner students
um who uh you know are throughout our
system students who are persistently
bullied
um and again that's as it's defined it's
not a capricious definition in terms of
what's persistently believe is the
definition of RSA 193-ft colon 3. a
student with a disability
a student who has a manifest education
hardship would be eligible to
participate
irrespective of their income limits and
then a student who lives in the
geographical boundaries of a district as
identified as a CSI school which is our
lowest performing schools would be
eligible so if you're in a
non-performing school you'd be eligible
and then a student who is in a school
that's defined as a persistently
dangerous school and again that's a
statutory definition for what a
persistently dangerous school is
generally dealing with felony events
occurring in the school environment
and then finally a student who is a free
and reduced price meal student and again
as an example those are students who may
otherwise qualify anyways
I believe that we did pass that bill
okay so I didn't know if we need to have
more conversation here or not so so yes
uh House Bill 367 changed on page 57
line 17 uh that sub paragraph a the
threshold for income to be 350 percent
that's then that's one difference from
what we have here in front of us in
House Bill 2 and then also in House Bill
464 that next sub paragraph B I don't
believe exists the 500 percent just did
not exist did not exist in 465. so those
are the two variances that jumped out of
me between what passed the house last
week versus what you had before you and
house bill 2. I'm of the opinion that we
modify this to match what we passed in
the house
and that Amendment isn't drafting I
don't have it to to pass out today it's
in OLS now being drafted so uh
it can be done today if you if you
choose to or wait until I have the hard
copy but that that's what is in the
crafting just the technical question
since it's a bill that was passed why do
we need an OLS amendment is the language
different in hb2 correct it is different
house bill too I'm new yeah no so uh
there's always different approaches here
one is to not have a part of household
two and have it pass in another another
is to have it both bills but usually you
would want a uniform so you don't pass
two separate uh right positions on the
same statute
so can I says Mickey a clarifying
question so under subparagraph 6B when
you say that that was
that language was excluded from 464 I
think is what you just said
but it wasn't all of B Because B
includes all of the subcategories that
we've just reviewed
I'm sorry it's specific to just be as
far as 500 questions
subcategories are there just without an
income
Everybody follow that one
okay
yeah just two quick questions uh one
really quick
um do we have any where the language go
persistently what is it called
persistently date no do we have any
persistently dangerous schools in New
Hampshire and the second thing is a lot
of these students it seems would have
some
um relationship with Youth and Family
Services or DHHS so there's got so
they're in they're in that system and
for good reason how do how will these
things interface if these kids are
pulled out if they're not in the public
school
um so they would still be eligible for
all of those HHS types of programming
this would just allow either the parent
or the guardian or the surrogate parent
like we have surrogate educational
parents that may find that that student
in a particular education setting is not
being successful and really needs to
seek an alternative I mean as an example
of that uh even this weekend I received
a call from Foster families who the
student is in an educational setting is
experience a foster kid so it's being
fostered so I'm hearing from the foster
parents and is in a situation probably
because of the child's Foster status is
receiving some bullying in school and
and got placed into that school because
of the Foster relationships and so the
parents were seeking whether or not they
might this student would be eligible
because through an education Freedom
account they would be able to redirect
their the education to another study
that they thought might be more
appropriate and
if to do something additional in order
to work with the children Within These
systems or do you still foresee an
additional burden to DHHS I don't it
would you use the same systems
which is do we have any I forget the
words it's such a persistently oh but we
do not we measure that every year we
like to try not to have that we we did
have a scare recently that we thought we
had some and then we went back and
looked at some police reports and
determined that those were not the types
of charges that would have resulted in
that
Mary
thank you Mr chair commissioner
you've expanded the categories quite
significantly
my question to you is can you assure me
of the safety of all the children
receiving efas and the environments
within which they are placed
I am highly concerned about number one
the accountability of the learning
environment number two the safety
of the children I've been around for a
long time and I have seen some pretty
nasty stuff
within some families that
I was quite shocked that these things
would occur in how and can you assure me
that children will be safe
so thank you for that question
representative Heath and I share your
concern to make sure that our children
across the state are safe and we are
doing all that we can to make sure that
children are safe and as you know we
want to make sure they're safe in let me
just finish for a moment um in any of
the educational settings that we have
them in and as you know when you say can
I assure you I don't know that I can
give you 100 assurance that they're safe
in my traditional public schools and as
you know we have educator misconduct
that takes place uh students are exposed
but we put in place programs we put in
place security measures we put in place
various screening measures to try and do
all we can to make sure that those
children are safe because none of us
want to see something happen to a child
just a full thank you Mr chair
so in my many years of being an
administrator and a teacher
um
I have had to report numerous incidents
if I had not been
in the position I was in to report those
behaviors
they would have continued
and I have to say
somehow someway I hope that within your
scholarship organization or your
department of Ed or whatever you're
doing that there's some kind of
guidelines put in place because I I told
the governor's office the same thing I'm
really worried because we have over 10
000 children being homeschooled we don't
know what the environment is
um
I mean we've all read stories with the
book education we read her book and
that was not in New Hampshire
fortunately but I mean I just have to
say that so often in the incense
incidences where
violations and perpetrations of children
have occurred it's been the Educators in
our Public Schools or public charter
schools that have identified those
behaviors and have reported them who
will report
to dcyf
how will we know
yeah and as you know in New Hampshire
we're all you know mandatory reporters
right so wherever that context is
whether it is a child who is being
abused in public school or a child being
abused outside of a traditional Public
School setting in one of these other
approved education programming we are
all mandatory reporters and have an
obligation to make sure that we're
looking out for our little
other comments all right thank you thank
you uh stormway Thunder that's 169 I
believe isn't it I believe so 0.69 C
right and uh also
um back in my earlier travels uh
Mrs Barrett from dcyf
uh and as far as homeschooling is
concerned they had one educational
neglect
in her tenure so that that says a lot
so the most
these bills
is it the
amendment to to to amend the hb2 to
match the bills yeah that's what the
amendment would do would replace Section
163 and House Bill 2 with essentially
the combination of 367 which goes from
350 to 350 300 to 350 percent for the
federal poverty income threshold and
then 464 which is essentially removing
that 500 threshold on the expanded
categories okay so you would leave it in
hp2
correct and it would it would align with
367 and uh to just to make them align
yeah Okay so
right second right now all those in
favor
for all those opposed
four to three
we move forward with that item okay
so we have a number of additional items
I'm not again I don't know which ones we
want to tackle first I'm I have until
okay so most of these are adequacy and
we're not doing those today I'm told
okay
168.
I think 164 maybe we could touch on real
quick okay education trust fund
distributions and allowable uses correct
nope
page 58 so we're on page 58 education
sections 164 167 education trust fund
distributions and allowable usage and
I'm going to let Caitlyn kind of walk us
through those
so much of this is a kind of a rewrite
of the allowable uses of Education trust
fund
um funding just to clarify the current
uses of the education trust fund
um specifically a lot of most of these
programs are already being paid out of
the education trust fund
um the first one that we're discussing
is just clarifying regular adequacy the
distribution of
um charter school aid we actually
reference the wrong section of the law
and the current loss or making sure we
reference the correct section distribute
Public School infrastructure grants
those are the grants we discuss in
detail on Friday those are currently
being paid out of funding that's being
transferred from the education trust
fund so we thought it would be good to
add it here as an allowable expense as
well but it's currently being paid out
of with education trust fund money
um the next on the list is to distribute
kindergarten grants again already being
paid out of the education trust fund and
at the time we had language
um
at the time when we had put it in the
educational fund as an allowable expense
the legislature I think was still very
much up in the air and what kindergarten
funding and grants would look like so it
was more
um General language and we clarified now
that we have a finalized kindergarten
programming program rather
um to continue on through the list
um
we allowed a distribution of funds for
RSA 194f which is the education trust or
education Freedom accounts again the
education Freedom account specifies that
those funds should be paid out of the
education trust fund under RSA 194f
which establishes the program
distribution of lease a chartered Public
Schools this is a change the Department
of Education requested in its budget we
felt that Charter School lease Aid
should be paid on the education trust
fund rather than the general fund as it
um is similar to the building aid
program and we felt like there was a lot
of Nexus there and and moved that to the
education trust fund during this budget
is a five or eight hundred thousand
dollar total appropriation in the
education trust fund that used to
previously be made in the in the general
fund
costs associated with the Statewide
Assessment program we discussed that in
detail again on Friday
and then the one change that you'll see
there which is a change for just this
biennium is allowing the education trust
fund to pay for funding relative to
career and Tech education renovation
programs um so those are kind of two
different pieces that we can pay we can
discuss in total and then the last line
in there is allowing the Department of
Education to retain funding from the
education trust fund to administer
education trust fund programs
um so those are all the changes that
we've made do we want to discuss any of
those in detail or have questions of
those in detail question Dan so just to
make sure I understand there is really
only one new use that you mentioned
everything else you are just asking for
that
chapter to be updated to reflect the
various ongoing uses of the fund that
kept being codified you know by the
legislature in various years right
there's two new users
oh sorry I mean
in the seats
but basically okay I got it I appreciate
it
this could I ask is this a section where
one percent of the education trust goes
to the Department of Ed this is correct
I would ask that that be removed
I actually would like to take a moment
to kind of talk about that and relative
us writing that language
um so we added this language to allow
the department to have flexibility when
we're administering a lot of these
programs now
um chairman Weiler actually brought up a
pretty good point on Friday when he was
talking about different programs and
other people running programs other than
the Department of Education because then
the Department of Education doesn't
necess the Department of Education
continues to come back to the
legislature ask for positions as
programs expand so over time the
legislature has expanded many of these
programs substantially adequacy is a
great example 10 years ago when I was
running the adequacy formula it was a
pretty basic formula now there are many
sub grants within that formula there's a
lot of data needs that are associated
with it there's a lot of technical
assistance that is needed to be provided
to school districts to Charter Schools
to the legislature
um and we have the same level of staff
that are continuing to operate these
exact same programs representative
Weiler was talking about
um even though a program has doubled the
program hasn't come back and asked the
department or asked the legislature for
additional programs that was because
that program has an administrative set
aside and so that as the program grows
and expands an administrative set-aside
is actually an allowability of that
program too and allows the program to
have that flexibility over time rather
than coming back constantly to the
legislature saying we need another
position we need another position
um and overall the department has not
necessarily been as successful as
getting positions that we need to
operate programs and this has been a
huge constraint on Department of staff
so
you know actually kind of said one thing
to it I mean so this year as an example
we are required under federally to
publish our school performance report
cards and we were somewhat late getting
those out simply because we didn't have
the staff to do the data extraction and
uploads so I
understood I understand all that
definitely but to me one percent is an
open pocket book there's let me finish
please
if you are seeking those additional
positions if you have needs I can
understand that but this one percent is
just nothing specified
I can't support that there's especially
under the current Administration I'm
sorry I don't mean to insult you face up
but it's true
um
it just it's it's I can't I didn't know
of no other department
that's a lot of money that you're asking
for
especially right now so I cannot support
that one percent and I just
I know of no other department that from
state
public
tax property funds would get without
specifications of what you're going to
spend it on on a yearly basis if if this
is going on I I just I think it's wrong
I can't support it I think I understand
your needs I get that I mean been there
done that and we
um had a hard time even finding anybody
but we're in a climate right now where
we are in good condition
we may not be in the future I I just one
percent of of a lot of money is is um
without any specifications of how you're
going to use it is too much for me to
approve so all we're asking for is the
authority to use this funding um we also
would assume that we are we're not even
at this time asking to appropriate those
funds we assume to use those funds we
would have to appropriate those funds to
which we would have to go and do a
budget and say you know this much when
money would go to class 10 or class 50
or whatnot
um all we're asking for right now is the
author of the authority to if we don't
have the ability to potentially
um
to operate the programs with the with
the staff and whatnot that we would need
we would I'm guessing come back to
probably the official committee or in a
future budget say all right we we can
have one percent of these funds and then
this is how we're going to do X Y and Z
I also do want to clarify that these are
not would not be property tax funding um
funds because these funds are
um would be other Revenue that's going
into the education trust fund as the
property tax funds never go into the
education trust fund directly so the
department would never have access to
that
so we're not asking for no transparency
all this funding would hit our state but
our state books
um we would work with the legislature
like I said probably through fiscal or
other future but um to to do so and and
so when you're seeing if you look for at
a budget first say like title one where
for example where we have one percent of
that 40 million dollars to run Title One
um you see the amount that's flowing
through and then you also see the
amounts that are being retained by the
department and we would expect a very
similar thing so we are at this point
we're just saying just give us the
ability to and if we feel like we need
to come to the legislature we then have
this kind of mechanism right now we have
no mechanism at all to fund positions
and support for the Department as we
continue to grow these programs and
continue to do the work to comply with
the laws so if if that this helpful
representative Heath um even in my own
like you know I'm not too big on
spending any more money either so
um but one of the things that you know
appeal to me about this is it is
consistent with the federal approach to
trying to do it right we get a grant
then we get a percent set aside as you
know that's how it works and and then
what we have to do is we got to go argue
we don't have positions for this so it's
not like you can just I can't go to
spend it on something I still would have
to
get this legislature to approve a
position to be able to use for it but I
understand your your concerns
Jim
given that this is a new concept and I
appreciate the explanations but I would
appreciate if you wouldn't make a
decision on it today I kind of want to
sleep on it and wrap my head around it a
bit more but this is very informational
it's just I don't feel personally ready
to make a call on it right now just
because you know again I need a bit more
time I find that when I sleep on stuff I
get a better idea by the next day what
line is the one percent on I'm trying to
read this one
okay
if I may while you're doing that um for
the record will you say what one percent
is 10 million dollars approximately
I'm sorry
10 million and the other question I had
um I think we'll go back to this but
just since I have the mic on right now
um I propose the just for the biennium
the Career and Technical education
renovation projects are you specifically
looking at Sugar Hill yeah in fact
that's when I did want to spend some
time talking about it as specifically is
the Sugar Hill project which was not
included in the capital budget so we
went to Capital committee last week
generally the legislature funds two CTE
Center renovation projects per year this
year one was included in well both were
included in the agency budget the
governor pushed forward the Sugar Hill
project because the winner Squam had not
yet received Community approval
and because of the surplus funds that
were available in the trust fund he
moved the Sugar Hill renovation into the
education trust fund and then we also
spoke to the capital committee about the
winter Squam project they would have
their vote at the end of this month on
like March 25th I believe it is what we
want to just be careful of is that it
doesn't get lost in the cracks between
you know Finance having it in terms of
the use in the education trust fund and
capital and each committee imagining
that the other body is taking care of it
but these are important projects for the
state we hope that we're able to move
those forward we spoke with the chair of
of capital three okay yesterday okay
wonderful
you won't see it twice okay sure I just
I'm worried I don't see it at all right
that's what the question I had was uh to
clarify
uh whether it comes out of capital if it
comes out of educational trust fund in
other words you're saying it just can
come out of Education trust fund is that
what you're saying it is certainly
eligible to come out of the education
trust fund and we and again we just are
advocating that the renovation is funded
and we're not bias we don't care where
it comes from
and I think and I think the uh
Commissioner's Office does a great job
sure will this go through this
through this year as if it were a
capital project does Sugar Hill have do
they have their ducks in a row or are
they kind of cutting the line here a
little bit nope not cutting line at all
they were in the queue and we had
proposed them as a capital project in
our agency budget they have all of their
um the information together we can
provide the committee with the
specifications in terms of the drawings
and the plans they have already received
voter approval for this and they're just
waiting for the legislative approval to
move the project forward that project is
shovel ready like as soon as this gets
approved on July 1 they can put a shovel
in the ground
okay my question on this one percent is
if that disappears what does it do
it it doesn't do anything at the at this
time because it's just allowing the
department to use the money if if we
come to you in the future and ask for
that right now the department doesn't
even have the authority to use that
unless otherwise appropriated
we it's just been historically the
legislature has been relatively adverse
to adding new general fund positions to
the Department of Education however has
continued to add additional requirements
and Reporting and grants and whatnot to
the Department of Education on existing
staff and so we're forced to do several
different things one just put it on
somebody else's general fund plate and
hopefully they have the time to do it
but then you know that transpensive
drive good employees out to ask a
federally funded employee to do that and
now that which we can't do with time and
effort but even if they could then they
end up missing missing Federal deadlines
which that's the commissioner just
reference or three not doing it at all
which we if you the legislature is
writing a law and requiring the
department to do it you know we would
like to comply with that law and that
requirement but we don't have the
capacity to continue to do all of these
things without additional support so
it's positions it's it's some sort of
authorization that that's all we're kind
of looking for going forward right so
there's no appropriate creation at this
point in time
um but if you didn't hear it in her
voice so Caitlyn's feeling the pressure
and her because it falls to her
Department right uh you know as we
because we have a basic adequacy funding
formula and then we add a you know
differentiated Aid or then we add you
know relief Aid and extraordinary needs
and grants right and every time you do
one of these like we have to go back and
recalculate this for every single
community and um and it becomes
difficult to keep up with you all quite
frankly
thank you Mr chair
um Mickey is there I understand
um
I'm troubled just by the language of the
how it's done is there another way
to
provide them with something but not
10 million dollars is a lot of money on
a yearly basis
um help me here so
so yes this this does set up similar to
a federal or non-state funded program
where you would have a cost allocation
to allocate State cost to a non-state
cost not non-state funded Grant or flow
of money so this is trying to tap into
State funds to fund something that is
otherwise state funded salaries benefits
administration at the Department of
Education what could be done here is to
add unallowable use of the education
trust fund the administrative costs at
the Department of Education subject to
amounts appropriated
that way
it's not an open warrant so to speak and
then whatever you appropriate Caitlyn
had mentioned they come and ask for
positions or you know whatever is funded
in here could be education trust fund as
a source of funds what we also heard
from here is coming to fiscal there's
there's nothing there's no law now that
permits the Department of Education to
come to get Appropriations through
fiscal similar to how dot does with the
highway fund for winter maintenance for
instance so if that's something the
committee wanted to do to give
uh an option for the Department to come
to fiscal
in between budget sessions I guess that
that's something as well that you could
do
that would make me feel a real lot
better
um it would give you what you want it
would give you the authority to go to
fiscal
um I'd be really happy with that
language rather than the one percent
just it just
I just can't do it but I mean I'm only
one vote so and I will say this section
is still there's a lot of other moving
Parts in here depending on what this
committee does with the rest of the
education trust fund programs if you
choose to switch them from General to
education there's been some talk about
moving some programs from education back
to General so this would definitely be
one you'd want to hold today and we can
work as a committee to deal with
everything up to the one percent uh
section and then that one percent
section as well something that works for
the committee and the department perhaps
if you're if that makes is a comfortable
comfort factor let's go down that road
so something to the tune of uh listing
that appropriate or ex let me back up uh
administrative costs for the Department
of Education as appropriated by the
general court would be an allowable use
and then come up with something where
fiscal could be uh they could go to
fiscal for additional funds above and
beyond you know at any other time
do you want to wait to vote till we have
that Amendment or are you comfortable we
would need
for that provision we'll tentatively be
okay with but like I said there's other
things happening in here for one like
yeah so so you know we there's a lot of
other programs that are going back and
forth General and education we've
discussed so once all those settle this
uh going to fiscal for doe will be part
of that Amendment okay
like I'm fine either way but honestly I
think that language is probably the
right way to go and we don't have to
finalize it today but it's definitely
something we should prepare and have it
there because it it makes a lot of sense
and it does address the you know
legitimate concerns that one may have
over the current language so I think
it's a good story if I can just if
everyone just real quickly switches to
page six of this packet I think it's
part of your package to commissioner so
this is the education trust fund
snapshot through the changes that this
committee has made to this point so if
you look kind of starting on line 32
you'll see some of those programs have
0.23 but now you see them so those are
most of the ones that are being added
and that you'll see as we stand right
now there's 104 million dollars of a
surplus balance at the end of the
biennium in the education trust fund
this is where we've had past
conversations as to
what you want to do with that whether
you want to add more things to the
education trust fund or move revenue and
programs out of the education trust fund
so whatever you decide to do with this
budget picture this RSA this section
here should align with that and I think
we're we're not there yet well I think I
think that a finance chair is of the
opinion that we've got to whittle down
the education trust fund back what it
was originally designed for and move a
lot of this stuff back into General
funds but I don't think we're ready to
do that this cycle
okay next section next
so I'm just skipping hit I actually have
um let's stop that I need to be able to
get to uh Cami and Caitlin will be able
to stay here and answer any additional
questions but I'm just starting are
there any
any of these areas that specifically you
want me to weigh in on for you and I'm
happy to jump ahead to those could we do
the um uh court ordered placement and
the new law that we've just passed
um and talk about how we're going to do
that
I was thinking that maybe
um
the the I don't know the language uh
representative your bill I'm just trying
to remember the number but yes so in
that bill there's going to be an
allocation
organization
location specified in court order
placements
um that seems like a good place Mickey
have you been working on that so uh it
doesn't have a page number but I think
the the last page of the pay-per-clip
pack that I passed out this morning I
got a memo from uh Rebecca Ross I hope
hope it's partier I think it is Rebecca
Ross who if you recall from Department
of Health and Human Services came and
spoke to us about this last week so she
had thought you know just off the top of
her head it could be around two million
dollars she went back and crunched the
numbers and you can see it's more like
four and then five million dollars in
the next two years associated with house
bill 521. so the the details that she
gave you there or they gave us there I
think it's in each of your packets so
yeah it's in line 168. so 168 in House
Bill 2 takes the traditional court
ordered placements and moves that from
the general fund to the education trust
fund so just to explain what quarter
Replacements are for you so I mean these
are basically students who are
adjudicated by the court system and the
court places them in a particular
education setting could be it's a new
new center or it could be some other
setting
um and by law we're required to pay for
the cost of those and the way that that
works is if we don't have enough money
we just draw warrant and we're able to
pay for them like there's no limitation
however the whatever the judge orders
that's what we're required to pay and so
this has been moved from the general
fund down into the education trust fund
in this budget
what was the bill number Mickey
House Bill 521 thank you sorry too many
Bill numbers
we're expanding this we're not actually
expanding it like we generally are
paying about that amount so typically
what happens since I've been here
through the last two couple biennium you
know initially we were at one point we
would budget like 1.5 million
um and then we increased it to 2 million
we've been spending more than that but
when you're passing a budget it's
General funds and so it's easier to pass
it at 2 million and then I just have to
draw a warrant for the excess anyway so
it doesn't show up in the budget per se
um so we're just giving you the number
that we estimate what the cost will
actually be and then you'll appropriate
whatever it is and then we're going to
spend whatever we have if we were
expanding it to include more than just
court ordered correct 521 commissioner
adds episode of treatment correct so and
that's the estimates that Ms Ross from
HHS has provided with associated with
that bill okay
so we were going to try to rename it as
well so okay court ordered and episodes
of treatment okay
yeah and basically the the intent is to
can I oh so and I just so then I'm just
going to clarify because I know I am
familiar with this legislation and maybe
I'm going to say what you were going to
say and I apologize
um but I mean essentially what in
addition to we've historically had the
quarter Replacements
um but what happens is
um under the fast forward program dcyf
is able to place students so a kid you
know calls in having a mental health
crisis it could be the rapid response
team that shows up at her house they
could show up at one of our hospitals or
Hampstead Hospital and the fast forward
team puts them into a specific uh you
know educational setting and so it's not
just a court it's dcyf making those
placements as well so we under this
program we would be required to pay for
that as well right correct and that was
the intent of the bill right I'm one of
the co-spons so that's not the prime
sponsor but
essentially the concept is that since
the you know the schools don't really
have any control over that placement it
is unreasonable to ask them to pay for
it so it is an expansion it is very
similar to the court order placement but
it is through a different program and
what representative Heath was talking
about is that we are trying to figure
out the best way to the line item to put
the funds in not just the amount but
where to put them in it does seem that
since this entire statute you know works
the same way whether it's a quartered
placement or a placement for an episode
of treatment that we could use the same
line item for both and just rename the
line item to you know court order or
episode of treatment
you know and that's what we wanted to
hear from you whether you think that's
the good practice or we should maybe
keep them as two separate line items and
then we'd have to change hb1 you know
what what are your thoughts on this so I
prefer having the transparency and the
visibility into them because quarter
placement is separate from an episode of
treatment placement and one is driving
through the judicial system and others
coming through Health and Human Services
and I think it's important as the
legislative body to monitor you know
what these different like to not
commingle those and then we lose
visibility so
so that would require
yeah so uh what we could do is just add
a new accounting unit House Bill one
yeah so I don't know if anyone's in the
mood to flip their big book open but
you'll see the court ordered placement
account on page 1149 so we could set
something up similar to that to the
episode for the episode of treatment
payments if that works in the department
it was so close
it's budgeted as education trust funds
now for court ordered placements are
traditional so this gets back to the
conversation it depends on what color of
the dollar is that you're going to do
with all these placement Appropriations
and I'll take care of that
when we get to that okay
so I never meant to co-mingle the funds
I wanted them to be two separate
entities
um but that kind of um
authorization seemed to work well that
we could do the same kind of thing yeah
I would think because it is a an
estimate you'd probably want similar
open Wars right actually the department
that should how would you allocate for
this is not enough they have a mechanism
to draw it just don't necessarily go
along with these recommended dollars
these are what will budget if if the
committee wants to this is what will
carry as a cost associated with House
Bill 521 but they'll still have
statutory authority to cover extra yeah
okay so just to clarify Mickey right now
the court order line item is 3015 the uh
you know Port order placements you are
looking to create a 3016 or whatever the
available code is that is consistent and
matches all the chart of account
specifications that would be treated in
the same type of legal fashion as this
where we attempt to budget the exact
amount but we understand that we may not
know so we will leave the authority of
the you know commissioner to draw as
needed because there is no way to
accurately modulate this type of stuff
but I would appreciate it if instead of
being a bit optimistic to pass a budget
and then knowing will overspend it later
to try to do our best therefore to
correctly estimate and put those numbers
in the budget in the first place and you
know then we can miss high we can miss
low but I think that whatever number we
put there should be our best estimate to
you know what we believe that may be
knowing that it's still a crap shoot at
the end of the day and we do the best we
can but so to throw that in there like
so we estimate that our quarter
Replacements are going to be about four
and a half million dollars it looks like
the HHS is estimating you know between
three and five million dollars for the
episode of treatment placement so you'd
want to make sure that you appropriate
the equal amount so we'll be looking at
a Amendment
we'll have a we'll have an amendment to
House Bill 2 with all the content from
521 okay as well as the statutory
language required I think it's it's all
covered if I remember the bill just
added episode of treatment to the
statute four quarter replacement so it
probably already has that open one but
I'll double check that and then I'll
build a house bill one account so you
can see the separate appropriation for
the episode of treatment versus the
court ordered we may not need a major
Amendment because you know
we're going to need an amendment we'll
need right yeah
thank you can I can I just uh be this
becomes permanent this is not for the
biennium this is a permanent changer yes
anything is permanent but going forward
the expectation is that this continues
on that's an understanding
I mean as long as like the fast forward
placements in the episode treatment
placements take place what other item
would you want to
is there any yeah there any other
specific items for me before I have to
go
um the source of funding we had talked
about bringing it back to general fund
or education trust I think right now I'm
fine with the education trust we have
money um we might not in future years
and I think another legislator could
legislation uh yeah another session can
change that agreed
okay
moving right along okay is there an item
you'd like to discuss or are you all set
I'm all set let me just go through my
other page quickly
have we spent enough time on so
everybody understands the Sugar Hill
right so I don't have to talk about that
one
no I'm all set great thank you but
before the commissioner heads out just
looking at the very bottom of page two
the change to revenue distribution of
bptbt between general fund and education
trust fund which is something that you
know we were talking about not deciding
anything today but I just wanted while
he's here whether he has any thoughts on
you know those strategies of funding and
you know any thoughts on that topic so
the only thing I'll I'll say relative to
that and it's kind of following up for
the previous conversation that we had
when I was in this committee it's just
what we have is when these things were
set up we had funding sources that
inherently are growing right so if our
as our economy grows and we expand more
you're going to see an increase in the
the uh the funding that comes in
um inherently my population of students
is going to contract and get smaller and
so those two are going to probably
continue to diverge so as you consider
how you put funds into that education
trust fund we want to try and balance
based on what we think the needs are
going to be and those needs are going to
be based upon the numbers of students as
well as the programs that you decide to
fund out of there but I think the
governor's budget reduced it to 65
percent of previous numbers yeah the the
governor's recommended budget changes
the business tax allocation to 65.35
which over the biennium is about 150
million dollars of Revenue that would go
from so that it would go to the general
fund versus the education trust fund and
you do see that adjustment on lines 15
and 16 on that uh schedule uh the house
the on page six the education trust fund
schedule okay
we still want to hear from me anymore
you're on a roll I can't help myself
um this is an anomaly though this year
well
the last few sessions for us to have the
amount of funding that is in the
education trust we're going to be
heading into a recession
um I think you know we've all been
watching the news about what's happening
to the banks there are some concerns
about what's going on my my concern is
that um by limiting the amount of money
going into the education trust we might
be short shirting ourselves in case of a
recession and we'll end up
but we have the authority to take money
from the general fund
um so that's there but I just want to go
on the record as uncomfortable with
doing this thank you very much
thank you all right thank you
commissioner okay Caitlin back in the
hot seat
so which items where do we go now
8165 167. so building either they acted
on that last week though
so building it to this point the
committee has decided to remove the 75
million dollar transfer to the new
building Aid fund I don't know if you
have any questions for the Department
relative to the amounts that are in
House Bill one for new projects there's
still about 46 or 48 million dollars in
house bill one four new projects for
this biennium uh I think they had spoke
to that last time they were in but I
don't know if you have any other
follow-ups relative to building Aid no
just a reminder that is the tail The
Debt Service and then money for new
projects as well right
I would like to um
in that we still have remaining funds in
the trust I would like to be able to add
to the existing dollars in building Aid
so that we could cover at least five to
six projects and I know that Concord is
a big one so maybe it would just be
adding Concord
um in this biennium if that would be a
possibility for us to consider thank you
Mr chair it was like 37 million wasn't
it yeah
so if I could ask
I know that you told us when you gave us
that summary that those are the requests
and I understand that but it looks to me
like it should be possible to prepare
for us a if not fully accurate a much
closer to reality estimate of what money
may they may end up being eligible for
based on their number of students and
square footage and cost per square foot
would it be possible for the committee
to receive an updated you know summary
which contains that estimate rather than
the current yes way over you know
requests because it's kind of hard to
decide if you know where so far off the
Mark we're in the process of going
through and doing that calculation I
think we are down to number five on the
list which is Litchfield so we can give
you at least the first five updated to
give you what that number is um maybe
would it be possible to have a few more
maybe even if it's a ballpark we're not
looking for something that would be
binding to those you know just the
closer estimate that's all I'm asking so
um it takes a lot of time for the
Department to do that estimate
um so where that's where she's in the
process doing is going through and
reviewing all of the expenses and
determining what they are and are not
eligible for so that's
she can't rush it so she's gotten done
at least five maybe six or seven it
depends on really how much time so
um I will get the updated numbers with
those numbers knowing that the schools
still do have the ability to ask for
waivers and then and whatnot but I can
get you the the first five thank you
just looking for better quality data
understanding it's not gonna be perfect
but anything that improves the quality
of the data would be welcome and as
those things get updated if you could
just keep updating us throughout without
us having to ask anytime you know a new
school is done if you could update that
and send it to us I know that we don't
have a lot of time but you know it's
there is a lot of variability in that
data and we understand that so it's I
think that would give us an opportunity
to allocate more funding and so just a
reminder that there's a cap in law of 50
million dollars so all you would need to
do is do a removal of that cap one time
which I believe you did in House Bill 2
for this fiscal year I think or fiscal
year 22. so you would just remove that
cap and then appropriate whatever you
want to appropriate okay I understand
what you're saying yeah
yeah
right well we well we got 227 million
dollars worth of asks you know to for
building Aid and we seem so we never
cover what three out of 17 I mean that's
so maybe we ought to change think the
way we change uh we got some I think
that's nice
I mean well it's I mean we can't fund
them all but so somebody's gonna get
cheated out of the system so maybe we
should Target Aid to all schools
and let it go with that and then and
then have it in that fund uh Kappa
Reserve fund more to fall
I'm sorry over to follow won't fall
right no and there's more to follow on
that discussion right right well I mean
that's maybe we should head in that
direction and the tail we go where we
got to take there already in a minute
drafted Oh okay very good thank you yes
but Mr chair thank you
I will perseverate on my same comment
that I continue with school districts
have been on a moratorium for 10 years
um there are projects that have gone
unfunded
um there are we saw with my Cahill's
Bill we know we couldn't go back and do
retroactive but we have an opportunity
we have some money right now if we only
if we can fund put a few more projects
in and for this session I know you're
thinking about changing the manner in
which building Aid is going to go out
but just for this biennium if we could
at least look at putting a few more
dollars in building Aid well more than a
few more Millions I should say just so
that we can fund
um a few more of those projects that
have been on the waiting list and have
gone through the process with Amy and
have been vetted thoroughly that um we
could get them into the works just now
and I know you're we're talking about
other things
but just for this now that we have
funding in the education trust that we
could do this now I think that's our
intent oh thank you
of course yeah thank you I guess just I
don't want a little clarification yet
again
um it seemed our goal was to try to get
more building Aid in this biennium which
is why we moved that other the funds up
a little bit and
um
I guess I still would like to see I
guess I would like a recap of where we
are on that an apropos what
representative Heath was saying uh there
may be new methods or methodologies to
consider with regards to building aid
but I think that's a longer and larger
conversation with regards to unintended
consequences and if I can just point out
the discussion we had last week about
the accounting plans that were thrown in
and caused a huge uptick and a great
deal of extra work on people I think
before we do anything there needs to be
a good long conversation about what with
um Department of Education about what
those unintended consequences are so I
am very leery about any major change at
this point for that reason I can pretty
much guarantee there will be unintended
consequences if we don't do our due
diligence first and that we've this is a
great opportunity to get some of this
money directly out to some of the
schools who have been waiting for a long
time to do a building project thank you
I agree
well we're kind of in a holding pattern
on that one
so what's it what's next
I'm I'm I didn't have the department
prepared to dive into adequacy today I
didn't think we were going to have time
or I didn't think that conversation was
ready for any other items on here that
we could
section 178 Caitlyn
conference to Charter Schools so
um
178 gives the department flexibility to
make changes and and go to fiscal to ask
for additional funding if we are in
violation of our maintenance of effort
relative to our some of the federal
stimulus education programs that are
going on right now we are still in a
holding pattern with the U.S Department
of Education to find out if we would
potentially be in a violation of the
maintenance of effort this is carryover
language from the last biennium so
basically the legislature said you know
if the U.S Department of Education
determines that you're in violation
um you we will give you at least the
flexibility to come to us to ask for
more money so that's all we're asking is
to continue to hold for that language as
we're still kind of in that holding
pattern and then the one changes we did
note that last time we had only
specified for district schools and we
needed to add in the chartered Public
Schools as well because those those
schools also receive stimulus funding so
that's all that that language is doing
is just updating that that Charter
School language and continuing forward
that language to give us the flexibility
to go to fiscal if it's if it's needed
from usdoe
okay second
get all those in favor of section 178.
okay unanimous
can I just ask a quick question to
Caitlin is that that uh chapter law so
if you look on here I know there's a
type of drafting error if you look on
page 68 line 28 it says amend session
law 220 or 2001 it was actually session
lot 2021 so we could clean that up I
just want to confirm is that the
maintenance of equity Authority that you
have for the biennium only last year it
would only be needed for the biennium
because I think the federal law is only
looking at those two years okay so
um I don't know if we would need the
authority to go back if we should
clarify that but the calculation is
relative to the 22 and 23 school years
okay
no I think I think we're good with this
you can accept this as is I'll clean up
that uh that typographical error on line
28.
any other items you're comfortable
bringing forward
we're going to get her done to kind of
move today I see that and I appreciate
it
thank you
yeah because we're losing tomorrow
questions about the Medicaid directory
that's listed here Mickey is that
something that's coming up
on what I'm sorry
no no I think we talked that one to
death
is that a is that a section
right right okay yeah
can I ask about the cap again I mean I
know building a we need to wait on
um is a decision about removing the cap
for the biennium part of that discussion
so that'd be included yeah
correct
okay
well I don't know if I just messed
something up there's a little dial that
I just moved on the bottom of that so
maybe it's just volume I'm not sure
so was it on the page oh sorry on page
three line 43 when Caitlyn was with us
Friday she discussed the public school
infrastructure so that's still appending
the five million dollars a year relative
to that request I don't know if you have
any more follow-up questions for for
Caitlyn we we dove into that last week
if not we can move on to the
okay you go with that the accountability
position I think that request will go
away as well based on the conversation
that we had as far as repealing the
accountability plans relative to the
extraordinary needs Grant so as part of
this committee's adequacy amendment
however big or small that is that'll be
part of that okay and then that brings
us to lines 45 through 48 which tie to
those two schedules that I just provided
and the department can speak to the
requests as a position I do want to
clarify one thing was as far as adequacy
and whatnot is that there is a version
of a bill that came from the house that
has accountability plans tied to relief
Aid too so if you keep accountability
plans and relief Aid then it would also
need or the Sally fellows bill
right so I'm saying so that position
would be needed for that if you were to
establish that too so we'll be back to
that kind of circular conversation just
keep that language it's abolish of
everywhere
so and then
so the yeah so did I mean did the
committee continue to have questions
from the conversation we were having
last week relative to the positions
you know we kind of discussed them last
week
but these are not in hb2 HP one
so that this would be an increase to our
appropriation in hb1 for General funds
for these various different lines
relative to increases across the
department relative to hiring needs the
department has done in fiscal year 23 it
will have impacts on 24 and 25. okay I
remember that discussion
just I just was going to say that we did
follow up you know at the end of the
meeting because I wasn't sure during
that original discussion why they were
not included and it was made clear that
the timing of the budget process made it
impossible for this to be caught in the
budget so I'm completely satisfied that
you know this is the best we can do it
you know approve them at this time and
they are needed positions so I'm 100
fine with this these were not in the
governor's budget they were not in the
governor's budget now
the positions themselves were the the
hiring decisions have been made in the
last several months since we last
updated the numbers for the Governor's
budget Mary I think this is kind of a
simple conversation it's simply a matter
of the individuals who were hired to
fill those positions came in at a much
higher rate correct than was budgeted I
think the state maybe ought to change
that how they budget positions
um because this is a direct cause of
that
um so it's an adjustment based on the
new hirees
and in order to meet their budget they
need to make these adjustments am I
correct correct
so what uh
what's the motion on this one so you can
accept the changes in these two sheets
it'll uh it'll be a cost of about a
million dollars in general funds and we
would add 190 000 in federal as well to
the budget that would all be in house
bill one okay
all those in favor
okay
unanimous
and on page four of this document uh I
don't know if the department has any
thoughts on line 63 relative to the bill
to appropriate money to codify the
education laws and rules as well as line
69 which was House Bill 542 that
established the new data analyst
position
so this committee will remember about a
month or two ago I testified on that
bill um that was a bill that I had
worked on with representative Greg Hill
um for the recodification anyways
um
we have had you know continue to have
conversations I know people have
continued to do research
um I think that the general consensus
across the board from everybody on
whatever side of the political fence is
that the education rules do certainly
need to be looked at potentially
re-codified I think there are some
concerns maybe relative to the process
and the costs
um you know the point of the bill was
really to start having that conversation
um it sounds like this is not going to
be enough money which we anticipated
that originally we just kind of put
something down
um but something we are at a point where
something needs to be done about the
education laws rewriting them in
complete kind of form so that we're not
just doing this one-off piece by piece
so I spoke to resident Hill on Friday
about this and he indicated somebody was
was supposed to have given me a number
and I don't know who I don't remember
who he said
but apparently there's some activity
still going on but we don't have any
yeah yeah but let's see what that number
ultimately is because if it's like 10
million dollars we'll say well that's
big number I I might suggest
um maybe rewriting this language to be
something like
um require the department to put out an
RFP to do the work and then come to
fiscal with the amount in the RFP to
determine if that amount is reasonable
or not I that works I I would probably
support something like that because
honestly this is not going to work the
weight Street and I appreciate the
intent but I could argue that this is
either way too low for what you really
need to do and way too high for what you
can do so this is just
you know a conversation starter but
getting an RFP at least brings this to
fiscal who can say yay nay or cut it
down and just start the process so I
would totally authorize the department
to put an RFP out and go to fiscal as
suggested and take it from there so then
the the what we would do is we would
amend that bill no we'll put it just put
a dash B2 yeah yeah okay
Mary
um
I think we also talked a lot about this
is happening across the state with
regard to lots of different departments
so
um could this be more of a overall
Department of Ed being the first one to
do this to establish the protocol
by which the recodification of statutes
could be affected
um
I don't know if that makes sense and I
think from our work session on this we
there was discussion whether this should
be a well yeah a Department of Education
initiation or office of legislative
services and we had director alaconis in
here if you recall so perhaps
representative Hill was referring to
director alaconis relative to maybe
working on some information relative to
this bill and I can check with them but
I think to Mary's point if we if we
take pistol
general not just Department of Education
but any Department
authorize the department to get an RFP
and take it to fiscal
that would help Department
transportation could help safety could
help and that's uh and perhaps we run it
by director alaconis because it may make
more sense for one person or one office
to do that for all versus it just
scattered around state government fine
so maybe we'll touch base with him to
see if he has any information okay I
don't know if Charlie arlinghaus needs
to be part of that conversation because
it kind of impacts the whole the way the
state works
so I don't know just adding that well
they're the ones that actually do all
the contract review I'm sure director
aluconis will uh you know follow up with
Mr Arlington House or anybody else who
they should follow up I mean he would
know who to talk to to give us the
proper feedback
I don't think as anybody that has said
there's no point in doing this
every time I've heard somebody talk
about the building
people who never read the statutes May
disagree but when you actually try to
read the Mia it's uh right any other
items
um so there's other position
HB 542 new doe data analyst position
so this position was something that
representative Ladd had put in
um it's uh unique that the New Hampshire
Department of Education does not have a
a research and data analyst arm most
Department of educations I think have a
relatively large one and representative
Ladd was
really it came out of Representative lad
was at the Department of Education
asking for people to do X Y and Z and I
had said well we don't have staff that
are dedicated to doing that and if you
wanted that to be a function because you
wanted some reports he wanted some
substantial data data analysis on
education
just using our statistics I said you
know if you really want this on an
ongoing basis and the committee is
wanting these support and whatnot then
there should be a position established
full-time and he said yes and I want
that position and that because I want
he wants the results of of that so I
like that motion based on our previous
conversation this is a much needed
position our second emotion since this
is a 20-0 billion committee that passed
on conduct consent calendar I mean we
got a funded period end of story
I'm looking at Mickey because he's the
manicus it's all done yep so we'll put
this in House Bill 2 uh it's up to the
committee whether you want to fund this
position and the budget or just put as
an out as a house bill to appropriation
there's really no
right or wrong there we can keep it in
House Bill too that way how about 529
oh all in favor
we'll point out the bill appropriated
lower numbers and what the department is
saying is the actual cost so the bill
appropriated 160 and 145 000
respectively respectively for the next
two years and you'll see on line 69
there doe estimates 183 about per year
so use their estimates yeah
529 or 529
that's uh this is an ed funding bill and
I'm not sure how much you want to get
into that today oh okay yeah that one
that would see oh that's adequacy that's
that adequate example correct I like 529
seems like everybody does
so 529 maybe Caitlyn can speak to the
components that it adds
so so 529 keeps the formula the way it
currently is um away it's uh it's
different than the governor's proposal
so just a reminder on the governor's
proposal the governor's proposal is
really to simplify the adequacy formula
um get rid of some of the
um other kind of pots of money and
expand base Aid and free and reduce
lunch annual increases to school and
then
um as hold harmlesses go away increase
uh the extraordinary needs grants over
time so that's what the governor's
proposal does 529 is a different kind of
funding proposal that leaves the base
amounts the same leaves free and reduced
lunch the same leaves third grade
reading in the formula currently leaves
extraordinary needs grants in leave
stabilization grants in leaves relief
Aid in and then adds fiscal capacity
disparity Aid which is an old section of
the formula that existed prior to 2012
when it was removed in 2012 it is
largely based on family median family
income and equalized valuations and it
allocates approximately 100 million
dollars of additional Aid to school
districts across the state is that
correct 100 that's fiscal note
well just just one quick comment slash
question here
um
I remember that during the original you
know time when we when we had the public
hearing on the bill I did ask the prime
to sponsor whether you know at the time
when they designed it the governor
budget was not known so the bill is both
intending to change the way that it is
allocated and to increase it the
governor already increased Aid by a lot
so I would like to you know see if you
have any thoughts on uh you know
which whether you know the increase in
the bill is something that you know we
still need to add to the governor budget
or not because I'm quite uncomfortable
with that but just trying to understand
your thoughts on the bill both in terms
of the quality of the formula and in
terms of the amount of additional
funding now that we know the existing
Governor budget because this was
designed when the governor budget was
not known the bill
that is correct I I think they're
this is probably not the answer the
committee is going to want but the
formulas are just different and they do
different things and so really what the
policy there are two separate policy
decisions that the legislature needs to
decide which direction they're going in
whether it's increasing base funding to
all schools in the cost the
Constitutional cost of an adequate
education versus giving additional
funding on the
um quote-unquote right side of the
formula which is not part of a
constitutional adequate education
so those are two separate ideas that
um
that should be discussed just one quick
follow-up and that's a I'm new here
question can you point out to me why the
right hand side is the constitutional
eight and you know sorry the left hand
side is the Constitutional adequate
funding and the right hand is not
because in my head everything is sent to
the school is education Aid you know so
could you help me understand that of
course I don't have my wonderful law
book in front of me but um rsa198 I
think 40
um defines what the Constitutional cost
of an adequate education is and
calculates the Constitutional cost of
adequate education and just and that's
what that amount is and then everything
else is an additional it's it's
confusing because it's called an
adequate education grant but that is
outside of the Constitutional obligated
amount well that's why I'm asking
because I'm a bit confused and
clarification is welcome I appreciate it
I'll continue to go offline especially
just with the terminology being very
similar and kind of overlapping
appreciate it thank you
right uh thank you uh third graded uh
reading uh how valuable do you think
that how much effect does that have that
money and if we take it away uh what's
that going to do so um the third grade
reading money which I think
so I think it's approximately 1.5
million dollars in the current Formula
um and it goes to only about 15
um 100 Kids uh because of the way the
calculation is done
um the third grade reading amount you
are only eligible to receive that amount
if you're also not free and reduced
lunch special education or an English
language learner so there's
approximately 6 500 kids that would
actually be eligible for this aid but
because of those additional kind of
callers on the funding not everybody is
receiving that funding so if the funding
is truly going to increase third grade
reading there's a lot of kids that are
not proficient that are not benefiting
from those dollars at this time
so if I if I may follow up do you think
we uh it's not really effective I mean a
million and a half is I mean we're not
we're helping them in other ways anyway
so so in the governor's proposal reduces
that basically in that exact line of
thought that the funding could be used
elsewhere
so we'll leave one on the table
yeah I think Ed funding adequacy is
still wide open right now for discussion
yeah so anything else we can
cover today
all right thank you very much thank you
enjoy today's snow
I always will I love snow
I got a feeling Mickey's got some other
stuff for us yeah I do uh I'm gonna I'm
gonna pass something out real quick just
relative to 529 so very simply the
current law includes two enhanced Aid
grants as part of the Ed funding Formula
One is based on free reduced lunch
populations one is based on equalized
valuation per pupil 529
introduces a new aid grant based on free
reduced lunch populations and one based
on equalized valuations per pupil it's
to me very duplicative so I'm going to
provide the language that's in current
law and the language that's in 529 just
so you have it so you can see how
similar you how similar The Proposal
from the current life so it may be
repeating the same mistakes
I'm just kidding I'm just kidding
okay
part of that conversation too Mr chair
could
I'm confused about the hold harmless in
529 because I think the whole timeless
um even though 529 does a number of
things then whole time list also does
some things so how do those two interact
and how do we end up I think my
perception is that hold harmless is just
another name for uh yeah
I mean it's it's the same thing
well
yeah
by me with one difference that
stabilization is designed was designed
to be permanent while the whole harmless
is designed to be temporary and as the
funding Rises old harmless should slowly
well slowly or fast disappear right that
to me that is the difference and that's
why I'm gonna use different terms but
the goal is the same
if you will thank you
if you remember we would try we tried to
reduce home hold harmless uh or
stabilization uh what four percent
per year for and then we got rid of it
one two eight twenty eighteen so I mean
it's
I I don't know why maybe somebody can
answer that question I wasn't here well
I
make it you know why why I was taken
away or just that was like legislative
decision I can't speak to uh okay but
yeah that was just the when the formula
was redone
2018-19 whatever that was the
stabilization
decrease was essentially repealed and
restored back to the full amount at that
time when they did the formula I think
I've said this before you're probably
sick of hearing it the last time the
education funding formula was the same
statutorily for two consecutive years
was fiscal 12 and 13. so every single
year since then it's been a different
way of calculating it funding so
it's hard to remember each year why a
change was made and what that change was
but
okay
looks like you've got some videos I do
I'm gonna kind of go we're gonna be all
over the place a little bit try to get
as much done today as we can uh first
things first house bill 129 relative to
the hygiene products I had that
Amendment okay I think we just want to
take a look at that be good with that
and then uh
I essentially reconsider our previous
action of retaining this bill and then
we can bring this amendment as ought to
pass as amended next door across the
hall on Wednesday for the full committee
on this one
um
I think if I recall our discussions
yesterday correctly the committee was
leaning more towards just clarifying the
language that instead of it you know
that this is just removing the language
that says in the bathrooms right right
so that's the amendment look and change
changed girls to
administrating students
so any comments
who have a motion to adopt a member uh
zero nine three three h Joe okay do a
second Mary all those in favor
post yeah
okay do we need to reconsider the first
or was that just still sort of an
informal
I think we'll just make it clear that
this bill is no longer retained the
recommendation is ought to pass as
amended yep and we'll we'll talk about
that across the hall Wednesday okay
so also just to confirm the episode of
treatment bill that we're good with
that's going to go in House Bill 2 along
with the appropriation of house bill one
so we got that done
I do have
if you recall so on page one of our
packet for today page uh 44 section 121
the dot relative to the rights away the
prime Wetlands I did get a response from
the department and a proposed change
that you know they that maybe you could
consider based on the conversation
what would they say
I have a hard time supporting this
um I appreciate I'm a big fan of Dot and
um
and I it's my you know I am a fan of
Quinn you know we all get along really
well I don't these that dot needs should
get a buy from protecting the prime
Wetlands a lot of What DOT does does
damage to the wetlands and when they're
doing their work I think they should be
respectful of the value of the Prime
wetlands and so I don't think they
should be exempt from taking care of
them when they're doing their
maintenance within the prime wetlands
area so I don't think I can support this
all right
I was of the opinion that all this did
was eliminated a couple of the steps
that they could get around
the law if you want to call it that and
do what they needed to do this would
just eliminate a couple of steps and
make their drug easier that's the way I
understood it I might be wrong
thank you
very much I can just respond when he
says you know the change will clarify
the department does not need to adhere
to stricter Wetlands requirements so to
me it gets around what they should do it
gets around what they're required to do
to do what they want to do they'll
they're able to do what they need to do
while they are taking the prime Wetlands
into consideration
and so I don't think it's a num I don't
think it's just like paper steps that
they have to skip through I think that
they're actually changing what they
would do when they're doing the work and
that's so I have a problem with that I
think you know what they're doing around
the wetlands really does have an impact
on the wetlands and I think it's our
responsibility to protect those and if
it's a little bit longer work for them
you know I'm sorry but I
you know it may cost a little more now
it may cost a lot more when we damage
our Wetlands later on
it was
a planning board of conservation that's
it that's
yes I miss
the impetus how this fell in our lap uh
who is requesting this change as the
actual dot is requesting this okay
thank you if I may I mean my my
understanding of this and I would
appreciate if somebody would correct me
that my if my recollection is not
accurate is that this is intending to
clarify that people cannot come after
the fact when all this have already been
established and come now designated as a
prime you know Wetland and change the
rules and basically make it impossible
for the Department to use existing
easements
isn't that what what this was all about
this but but it's for existing things
it's it's things that are already in
place maintaining existing things right
which which should be here
but
that isn't that those the fact that
those things the easements have been in
place before and the you know and then
this is declared Prime Wetland and now
people change the rules and the
department cannot uh you know do their
maintenance work anymore
they have to ask they have to coordinate
with the town they are coordinating with
a town but it's just if this is done
post-facto it it could essentially be a
way for the Department to lose access to
you know culverts and easements that
they need to use as a
as a real estate attorney in my former
life
um who practice you know real estate
property law I think there are important
uh processes in place under current
statute that require the dot to go
through a formal administrative request
to go outside of the you know specified
law if they want to do you know
additional
you know incursions into these Wetland
areas to mean you know to maintain their
infrastructure so I think you know those
important steps have been put into law
in the past because there has been
um a perceived need for that you know
give and take of local conservation
commissions weighing in and other
stakeholders being able to to say hey
this particular piece of wetland
property has specific characters the dot
needs to come to us and we need to have
that conversation I think by changing
the statute by allowing them to have
that waiver without that conversation it
could be detrimental and so I think I
think um while it may make the Dot's
administrative burden a little lighter I
think that there's important reasons for
having that conversation take place
um and you know through those steps that
they'll need to go through so you know
understanding you know how projects take
develop over time and can have specific
characters for each characteristics for
each project you know given the Wetland
area and surrounding easements
or you know just the actual you know
uh these um these land survey maps that
you look at you know they can change in
character over time given you know
changes of our climate or changes of the
water
um riparian kind of flows so you know I
know there's a specific need to go
through these steps each time so I think
giving the blanket waiver is could
potentially have a lot of detrimental
effects that we're not really prepared
to understand
um in our capacity
just sitting from a fiscal committee
perspective I think you know my inkling
is to to say that
the processes in place have been put
there for a purpose and I'd like to
support that I'm not sure that the dot
should have a blanket waiver without
um
you know really
investigating each change that they need
and so you know I personally couldn't
support this I don't think that that's a
wise decision for our state because I
just know there are so many particular
um you know
perspectives that need to be taken into
account when you go through these
changes and you know as someone who's
worked on both sides of litigation
related to this I think it's important
um
you know making a big change like this
could have big implications and I I just
caution everybody from making a huge
sleeping change that's not going to be
helpful
I would just like to note that I would
prefer if we don't decide this today
feel the need to do more homework and go
back to the hearing and review the tape
of what was said at the time to refresh
my memory my recollection right now is
just not accurate enough to be able to
decide on it right now I think this is
this wasn't his uh only portion this is
this was one
a small piece of the whole section
there were multiple sections relative to
rights of way changes so two of the
three we were good with as a committee
and those were accepted this third one
was put on hold
and the sounds of things I think it
could stay on hold
or do we have to delete it
uh you if you still want to discuss this
at a future time whether it stays in or
not you can you can just keep this topic
on hold deleting it from House Bill 2 is
is always a an acceptable option for the
committee to if that's the direction you
want to go
so what you have is language the
governor put in House Bill 2 and then
before you propose change that language
the department provided at the end of
last week so it says nor to provide
mitigation which is a problem I mean we
do want mitigation and I think that the
local communities should have input
because they know better than dot or
anyone else uh the state of their
wetlands and I think in particular we're
going through a process right now you
know the environmental process not man
not we're not doing anything in
Newcastle but we have a wetland that is
likely changing from a freshwater
Wetland to a saltwater Wetland and it
requires different information different
stuff and I really think it's important
to have the local communities involved
when you're working in those areas
you've got you've got culverts that
especially with Newcastle we've got
culverts that are really small and
falling in which need major repair and I
think we have that all across the state
and I think it's really important that
we adhere to protecting those Wet Ones
okay
yep all right comment right uh
I think we're it sounded like uh the
d.o.t's Rogue and its uh actions and uh
that's not necessarily true because they
have to go by a scope of work
and they have experts that handle these
things and they do an excellent job
that's why we have good roads and we do
have and they they know the differences
and they I think they're conservation
commissions are great they're not
necessarily uh staffed by expert people
and uh you know I think uh this is a
another step because every time you
increase a step you can increase the
cost and I and actually I observed uh
firsthand uh when they were building a
spalding Pike uh I happen to uh stop by
my son's office who work for the state
as an engineer and I they they look at
turbidity of the water I mean it's and
the uh they have to and they have to go
by federal law too because you got uh
you know Safe Water uh considerations
but I mean it it they're they're so
offensive every I mean there's all kinds
of things it's not just you know they
they don't just go in there and uh you
know dig something up and let it go but
they have to go by certain rules
even even sell so you know we don't want
to add more costs
as a bridge we're not going to cross
today all right sounds good
uh I'll point to a couple of things on
this document we could probably deal
with on page three
line 42
you'll see something new here uh it came
to our attention in accounting unit 5032
that there was a for lack of a better
term I think it was keying error and
some Highway funds ended up in this
accounting unit but there shouldn't be
Highway funds in there so you actually
can make this adjustment here and
improve the highway funds position by
sixty six thousand dollars not not huge
but it cleans it up and you gain a
couple bucks
okay all those in favor
okay done
I'm going to bounce all over the place
here so if you look up on page on the
same page line 19. if you recall we we
approved this it's other funds this is
the fire fund that's administered by the
department of safety they'd asked for
these positions during that discussion
it was asked if part-time money could be
reduced to offset the full-time the
department did provide a memo here uh
I'll just summarize they did they do say
that their preference is to do the
action that you already took and the
fire fund could absorb that action
without an issue but I will give this
just so their follow-up is on record
with you
what's the action that we already took
19.
oh actually
whatever we do
if you could clarify for my recollection
what is that we already did because I
don't have those notes in front of me
on page three you'll see on on line 19
we added funding for three fire service
instructor positions out of the fire
fund and then during that conversation
when these items were discussed it was
asked if part-time money could be
reduced since they were considering
adding full-time uh this the action that
the committee took is the preference of
the department but they did follow up
with information they weren't aware that
you had taken that action Friday I think
so I had when I had updated Steve today
he had provided this memo so we thought
we would complete the request for the
follow-up information but you don't have
to do anything the invent of this memory
if I read it correctly because I'm just
seeing it is to say that
they are capable of funding two of those
positions from their existing funds by
transferring from the part-time and they
are just requesting one position
foreign
and I would move that we make those
changes because right I'm sorry never
mind me that's why I was asking what did
we already do so this stuff for
information only just so you'd have this
complete uh response from them I oh so
this was the confirmation that what we
did on Friday is totally fine with them
and to the extent that the fire fund
does have any Appropriations that aren't
expended it's a non-lapsing fund it
stays in there they administer it they
keep track of the balance that's uh
their responsibility thank you for
clarifying was a bit lost
don't have anything else that is in my
opinion a softball I guess just to clean
up either in house bill one or two or
any of our retained bills I don't know
if there's anything more the committee
wants to do today I know we have a
public Hearing in about an hour and 45
minutes
in reptile
so that's where we're at
I think we ought to make book on what
what the topics are going to be
I'm joking
I guess one thing is uh so we're not
going to meet again until Friday
uh is there anything specific that you
want to to work on Friday while we're in
committee I can have prepared
just getting stuff done I'm uh
I am available
it's uh
it depends it's hard to predict the pace
that will go on Friday and how prepared
we are to make decisions a lot of the
decisions remaining are so looking on
page three here there's a lot of general
and Highway funded requests from the
Department of Safety you do have some
fish and game requests here that are
mainly General funds they're not huge
dollars I think one of the
directives or directions that I think
the full committee is hoping is any
additions you make you're also making
corresponding reductions somewhere and
doing Net Zero which we haven't really
been doing to this point uh outside of
the 75 million dollar in the education
there's a lot of money in the education
trust fund right now
so unless we start doing funding swaps
you know moving some of the Gen the
education trust fund out into the
general fund and using the general fund
for some of these it you know so there's
there's a lot of a lot of potential
moving Parts here there's a lot of ways
to to go about this what do you think if
we devoted four or five hours to it on
Friday he would be able to resolve it I
think if we if if anyone had any
initiatives that you want to propose for
Friday to discuss versus you know so if
we came in with an amendment or a game
in with a proposal perhaps we could do
that Friday I worry that if we came in
and started a conversation from scratch
on Friday we probably wouldn't get too
far but if we had documents to work off
of some proposals or amendments I think
we could be productive Friday
I don't know that we have any we don't
right now no then that's what I'm saying
so uh so you know flipping over to Page
Six
we can see we've got an education trust
fund with 100 million dollars sitting in
there you know so some of those those
proposals or some of those programs
funded in there we've talked about
increasing ins in increasing School
building aid for instance or changing Ed
funding those would obviously impact
your bottom line we've talked about
moving some revenues out of the
education trust funds so those types of
proposals if anyone has anything like
that I'm not sure
I'm not sure where we're at I guess with
that conversation what if we posted it
for Saturday and if we don't need it
just don't go I mean that that would
work
I think we'd know Friday if there was
benefit to coming in the next day or not
or waiting until Monday so but when when
is the deadline for posting in the
calendar it's 24 hours to post any
meeting but we can uh you know we'll
I'll have Janet post it today so at
least it's on the digital calendar okay
I'd also recommend Mr chair at this
point with our budget work sessions that
you recess versus adjourn or end so that
way uh for instance we don't have
anything scheduled
on Wednesday but if we fly over across
the hall and get done very early and you
did want to call division two together
we could if you recessed today as an
example at the end of today which are
rapidly approaching yes we'll recess
until Wednesday or just recess and just
indefinitely we're recessed yeah yes I
recall it used to be that at some point
uh maybe earlier than now we got an
estimate of what they were giving to
each division got an estimate of what
they have we haven't gotten that yet
well
but that was just the revenue we are
also adding you know we are also
increasing the budget and we'll have to
find those budget those funds too not
just the 90 million but everything we
had something's got to come from
somewhere well a lot of them have gone
in the education trust me yeah but
usually we are given a proportion we're
given an estimate of how much goes to
div one div two and div three and I'm
not aware that we've gotten that
estimate yet not yet
so I think we're working through what we
can to this point and I would think by
hopefully by the end of this week we'll
have
a clear bigger picture you know so some
of these decisions of can we afford two
hundred thousand dollars for this maybe
one better idea by the end of the week
um
I don't want to say hopefully but
hopefully because that would mean we're
we're making progress right so I hope
hopefully we'll be in a good position to
have a long day Friday we have any bills
uh Wednesday
across the hall in full committee yeah
yeah two bills I'm just saying we do
oh I'm asking
what I'm going to is I'd like to have
somebody speaking to our bills
so
yeah
I'm I'm happily willing to let somebody
else speak to these thoughts
speak yeah whatever sure
what's today's
I think they were all unanimous this is
just the first committee uh the first
referred bills that we got so these are
the early ones I think for us everything
was either retained unanimous was 129
the hygiene products Bill and 207 which
was that just local school budget impact
there was no FN on that bill so I think
our bills are pretty
yeah they should be I think for
we only have two
we only have two bills that I think are
not uh retained but we still have to
make a recommendation of retain over
there and the full committee would vote
to retain okay
but I think I've I'd have to look at the
list again but I think it's only 129 and
207 that are moving along yeah since
it's going to be the others
if if it was it was just an ought to
pass I think this is our only amendment
it's just the one we did today
because on my mind is scrambled on
the whole committee meeting we haven't
had one more voting stuff out in a long
time so I'm just
and at some point I get the pleasure of
going over this entire hb2 and so we'll
yeah so on it all goes well Monday the
27th I think it is or whenever the
Monday is around there is when each
division will be presenting the
culmination of all the recommendations
to the full committee so all the changes
so we'll have uh one of those detail
change documents the legal size uh with
all the
each accounting unit essentially change
that you do in the operating budget and
then we'll have a house bill one and two
packet so it'll it'll be similar to this
with all of our amendments attached to
it that we're admending House Bill too
and that's when you would walk through
the detail change and the index and the
all the Amendments so if there's an item
on here
that is not affecting any we didn't
change anything it wouldn't even be
included in that document so it would be
included in your final full committee
House Bill too but you're only going to
speak to the changes that we're
recommending to one and two that I can
handle
all right
so 207 what was 207
I think 207 was relative to increasing
the threshold of when a local school
district has to have a public hearing on
a dollar amount yeah so I think it right
yep yeah and I I'd have to look at the
list but I feel like everything else was
retained and then there's the hygiene
bill right if I'd have to double check
but
but if there was anything else it was
not a significant believer everything
was unanimous trying to steal myself so
I don't like wake up two o'clock
Tuesday morning
panicked so now I'm I'm less panicked
that's more of a 5 a.m thing
well that's that's all right
but I think we uh
it's a that starts at 10 o'clock on
Wednesday as I recall yeah I think
there's a non-germaine public hearing at
10 and then a work session on 14 husband
49 again a full committee and then the
full committee exact on all the bills I
think starts at 11. okay
it's gonna be a long day
so everybody should take their Awards
name tags
right yeah the next meeting for us will
be in the full the full room
so we
so we take our own name tags right yeah
are you down with public hearing yeah I
think they'll have tables set up or
usually they set up like uh folding
tables in like the front of reps
I gotcha yeah
I forgot about you'll be in reps Hall
this afternoon hey it's still close you
can you should be able to leave your
stuff here no no it's cool I would have
missed it
two o'clock
yes
have you seen your email
for one year Dairy
matter of fact he was there complaining
oh don't you point fingers
rfm luxury
RSM whatever it is
okay
well that's true so we'll recess this
session
thank you